よろしくお願いします
今までは 13種類の心処の説明いたしました
この 13種類の心性の中に特色がございまして
それは善でもなく悪でもない
いわゆるいい心性とも言えないし
悪い心性だとも言えないんですね
単なる心理学的な心理的な働きなんですね
それ13 13の ですから
この普通のヨーロッパ的な心理学の立場から考えちゃうと
その13種類しか考えられない
仏教から当てはめないかもしれません
それから出てくるものはいくらかは関係ありますけど
この13にこのアンニャサマーナという特別な言葉があるんです
アンニャサマーナ アンニャサマーナチェータシカと言うんですね
アンニャサマーナというのは
アンニャというのは互いにという意味で
互いにサマーナとは似ているという意味で
そうしたっても意味が取れないんですね
アンニャサマーナ日本語でどんな言葉でしたっけ
ん？同タ心所ですか 同タ心所では他人と同じという意味で取ってますね
アンニャっていうのはやっぱり単体は互いということで
サマーナというのは同じと
で どういう意味かというと
このアンニャサマーナチェータシカの13がどんな心に生まれるかと
その心の特色を持つようになるんだと
もっと分かりやすく言えば
例えば悪い心に 不善なる心に
どうせこの13種類にいくつかありますね
7つは確実にありますね
そうするとその心性が不善心性なんですね
悪い心性 それでいいことをする時でも
大体こういう13のいくつかが生まれるんですね
その場合は その 13はいい心にカテゴリーをするんですね
ですから 悪いものと一緒になれば悪いもので
いいものと一緒になればいいものになるという意味なんです
自分では別に善でも悪でもない
善と一緒になっちゃったら善で
善で不善と一緒になっちゃったら不善になると
大体それぐらいのことです
少々スピードアップして進めていきます
今日は 今日のお話はアクサラチェータシカ
アクサラチェータシカ14種類
で テキストでは不善心所と書いてあるんですね
不善心所 で この善悪の場合は仏教では言葉を 4つ使っているんです
で クサラ アクサラ プンニャ
パーパと それはまあとりあえずついでに勉強しておきましょう
こちらが善でこちらが不善で
こちらは善でこちらが悪でということで
仏教では善ということに言葉 2つありまして
不善の場合も言葉が 2つあるんです
クサラ アクサラ プンニャ
パーパと で 哲学よりは道徳倫理の方が宗教ですからね
強烈に説明していますし
で なぜ言葉を 2つ使ってますかというと
その意味もありまして
で この一番下のプンニャ
パーパという言葉を 2つ入れますね
プンニャっていうのは
この仏教と あるいは宗教という立場から見て
人々はしているいい行為
日本語で言えば徳ですか
功徳という言葉を使っているんですね
一般的にいい行為というよりは
いくらかこの宗教の枠から見ていい行為ということになっちゃうんですね
いいことをして功徳を積むという言葉があります
ですから どんなことかと
いくらかは決まってるんですね
例えば仏教から見れば
何が何がいい行為ですか
何が悪い行為ですかと言えば言えばもう決まってるんですし
他の宗教でもこれは悪い
これはやってもいいというふうに
いくらかは決まってるんですね
ですから 宗教的な色は強いですね
プンヤパーパといえば
そこで仏教の解釈によって
例えばプンヤ 功徳を積んだ人は確実にいい結果が得られるんですね
功徳を積んだら その分幸福な結果が得られる
そちらの反対で パーパっていうのはアパということで
もう捨ててしまう 捨てられる
否定されるというふうな意味なんですね
ということは やってはいけないと決められている罪なんです
まあキリスト教から言えば人殺してはいけないとか
罪になるもの ですから
そういうパーパを行ったら罪であって
確実に悪い結果が得られる
で そういう 2つがありまして
例えば仏教の場合は 10種類に分けられて
例えば殺生 殺生することはパーパであって
盗むことはパーパであって
欲情ない行為をすることはパーパであって
嘘をすることはパーパであって
悪口を言うことはパーパであってというふうに 10種類がありますね
無駄話をすることも一つのパーパでありますし
噂を言うこともパーパであると
それから余計な欲と余計な怒りも 2つパーパであって
邪見ですか それもパーパであると
で この 10種類の中で
この特に我々気をつけてほしいのは
この余計な欲 余計な怒りなんです
それは異常欲異常怒りなんですね
一般的に日常生活の中で怒ったりするのはごく普通なことで
それでも地獄に打ち立てようと言っちゃったら
なんかちょっとかわいそうでしょうし
で 欲ね 欲もみんなにあるし
まあまあいろいろなことに欲があるんだからと地獄に落ちるということはないんです
そこはちょっと異常 精神的な異常な状態になったら
まあそこはまあ危ないと
世の中見ると結構そういう人々は結構見えるし
ですから  3番目 10番目に出てくるのは邪見ですね
とにかく間違ってる考え方だけは持ってはいけないんだと
で 間違ってる考え方を持っていたら
自分の行動をなんだかんだで間違えてしまっちゃうんですね
思考が間違っていると
いくら自分を守っていたって守れられないんですね
どこで何やってるかと
本人にも自信がないんですね
ですから この仏教の罪のリストの中で一番強い罪だと言っているのは
邪見と余計な怒りと余計な欲
その 3つの心の状態なんです
体でやっていることではないんです
ですから 心の状態が一番危ない罪であって
体でやっていることはそれほど大げさに考えてはないんです
なぜならば 体ではそんな大したことはできないんですね
じゃあ人殺すのは体で人殺すでしょうし
体で体を持って人殺す
たってもね そんなに大勢人を殺すことにはできませんし
一人二人殺された殺したところで自分も捕まれちゃいますし
あんまりたくさんすることはできないんです
よこしまないこういう仕事していても
それはまた決まっていて
そんなたくさんできないんですね
あっちこっちちょっと浮気するだけで
それで一人ひどい目にあっても大変なことになりますから
そんな大胆なことはできないんですよ
でも 世の中では体でやってる行為をものすごく大げさに考えているんですね
では 仏教の合理的な立場から考えると
そんなにひどい悪いことは人々にはできない
ただ泥棒するんだと言った
例えば銀行強盗みたいな大きなスケールの泥棒するんだと
まあせいぜい一つだけはできますけどね
2つはできないんですよ
ですから この体でやってる行為はそんなにそんなに強くなくて
それより口でやってる行為は強いんです
まあまた順番で言えば
頭で考える方が一番罪深い
口で喋ることはそれほど罪深くはない
体でやってる行為はもっと罪深くはないんだと
順番そういうランクなんですね
それ仏教のランク ジャイナ教だったら全く逆
体でやってる行為は一番罪深くて
中型は言葉で喋ってるもので
それほど大事ではないのは頭で考えるところなんですね
で 頭で悪いことを考えたって
別に悪いことしてないんではないかといって許しちゃがっちゃうんですね
あの人はそうじゃなくて悪いことしたんだよと
ですから罪が深いんだと
仏教はそれを認めないというか
それは違いますと 心の行為は一番多いんだと
罪深いんだと そこで体の行為は
説明しましたから 体の行為はもう決まってあって
そんなたくさんできない
じゃあ口で悪口言ったり噂言ったりするとどれぐらいできますか？いくらでもできるでしょうに
いくらでもできますよ
人の悪口言ってやろうと思ったったら
いくらでもいくらでも喋られるし
1時間 2時間じゃなくて
1年  2年  10年  20年
一生でも喋られますし
嘘を言っていいますと言ったったらね
軽い嘘から巨大な嘘までいくらでも言えるでしょうに
とにかく我々生きている世界っていうのは
ものすごいガッチリと嘘に固められているし
みんな嘘だとも気が付かないで
もう新聞の冊子記事やらもうほとんど僕は今90%ぐらい嘘ばっかり
自分で考えて考えて書いたりする
自分勝手な情報は事実というのはそれほどないし
書くは書くわと そういうのもはっきり言って嘘ばっかりなんですね
ですから嘘というのはいくらでも言えるし
悪口を言うこともいくらでも言えるし
コントロールできない
ですからこちらの方が罪深いんだと
それから人を傷つく場合は
人をぶん殴って何とかして傷つくともう決まってる
どれぐらい量が傷ついたと
でも口で何か言ったらその人を一生傷つく傷つくことできますよ
人をぶん殴ってちょっと 5分くらいで
10分ぐらいで痛みは消えちゃいますよ
怪我したっても それは 2
3週間で治りますし せいぜいできるのはその相手を殺すことなんですね
それ以上できない でもそれより精神的な痛み
心を痛む心の痛みは口で与えることはできるんですよ
人間は言葉で完全にコントロールされますから
言葉っていうのはすごい危ないんですね
ですからとても気をつけてほしいんだと
私たちも言葉で聞いて育てられてるでしょ
ほとんど言葉で聞いて
言葉で聞いて それで我々は自分の人生を設計しているんだから
ですから 言葉っていうのは大変なことなんですね
犬猫動物にだって別にほとんど言葉で喋って
いろいろ言葉わからなくたっても
それでなんとか理解して言うことを聞いてくれるし
そういうことで言葉の罪が深いと
それより深いというのはやっぱり頭の状態ですね
頭で考えちゃうと もうどんな罪でも起こさ起こされるし
それから罪が罪であろうがいいことであれば
それは心の問題だから
心自体腐っていると もう言うことはないんですよ
たまたま時たま人が怒って何か人を殴ったりしたって
心自体清らかであるならば
そこはまあちょっとちらっと
それはもう暗くなっただけで
それでまた明るい方向へ戻りますから問題ないんですね
心自体暗くて腐っていると
もうどうしようもないんですね
そういうことで 余計な怒り
余計な欲と邪見というものは
罪のリストの中で一番深い罪だと言ってるんですから
心の中を気をつけてくださいという風になっているんです
それはパープの場合は
仏教では10悪 リストがあります
今説明したのはその十悪なんです
同じく十善ありまして
あの前言った罪の反対のこと
殺生しないこと 盗みをしないことなどなど
そこでプンニャとパーパのことは終わります
例えば殺生しない 盗みをしないことの反対に恩施をしますとかね
生命を助けてあげるとか
そういう行為もプンニャに入ります
で それ次にクサラとアクサラで何ですかと
で クサラアクサラでクサラっていうのは俗的な日本語で言えば上手巧みということで
アクサラっていうのは下手ということなんですね
それぐらい軽い意味なんですね
だから巧みとそうでないと
巧みといってもすごい大胆な意味ではでもなくて
ですから その場合は我々のどんな行動も入る
あんまり厳密に宗教的な意味ではなくて
人間の行動は 幸福をもたらせる行動は何だかんだでも巧みな行動だと
不幸になる行動はそれほどないんだとかね
下手な人だと それぐらいの意味なんですね
だからもしかするとこういうことかもしれません
全ての功徳行為はクサラでしょう
だからって全てのクサラの行為は功徳になるということは限らないんですね
例えばきちんと勉強すると
ちゃんと知ってることは整理して
ちゃんと覚えてきちんと勉強
それはクサラの行為であって
だから天国に行きましたよっていうことはちょっとどうかなと
よく勉強できたんだから天国に生まれ変わりましたよと言ったら
ちょっとどうかなと 宗教的な立場で考えられるんですね
そうじゃなくて 人を助けてあげましたと
みんな悩んでる人々にいろいろなことをしてあげましたと
すごいいい行いをさせていたんだとかね
そういう行為をしたらプンニャなんですね
それで天国に行ったとは言えます
ですから クサラの行為の場合は
上手な行動 全部クサラな行動で上手
その上もうカルマとして生まれ変わったらいい結果が得られるぐらいのエネルギーを持ってる行動はプンニャで
というくらいのことで
6つの言葉で分けてるんです
それで仏教の勉強をする場合は
それほどプンニャパーパについてはそれほど喋れない
なぜならばプンニャパーパというのは決まってる
ある一定の行為だから
そこは大胆に持ってきちゃうと
なんか原理主義みたいな宗教になっちゃうんですよ
仏教は宗教的な特色をできるだけ控えてますから
例えばイスラム教で一番わかりやすくて
イスラム教 のプンニャの行為
パーパの行為 行為自体が道徳にしているんですね
ですから 確実に一日五回お祈りしなくちゃ大変であって
もういろんな厳しいんですね
いろんな面で それでそこまで厳しく生活できませんだから
イスラム教の人々もそれなりにもう楽に生活していると
ある一部がものすごく怒って
イスラム原理主義ということを作って
まあ徹底的にコーランに従って原理的に行動しなくちゃいけないと言ってるんですね
そこで問題もいろいろ起こっているし
どういう問題かというと
この中途半端でイスラム教を信じている人々はすごく優しくて
みんなと仲良くして で
本当に立派な人々なんですよ
そこで原理主義者はまあとんでもないことをやって
人を殺すはもうテロはやっているは暗殺するはもう
だからもう無茶苦茶なんですね
あのまあ あまり例を出しちゃうと
もうあまりにも話が他のところに飛びますからやめますけど
そういうこと 例えば仏教であるこの殺生してはいけない
盗んではいけないということとかね
で その金をお布施しなさいとかね
そういう話ばっかり言うと
なんか特別な宗教になって固まっちゃうんですね
でもクサラといえば巧みな行動と
アクサラといえばそうでない行動と分析すると
人類に一般的な論理として理解できるんですね
ですから そういうアビダンマとかそういうところを勉強すると
いつでもお経の中でも出てくるのはクサラ・アクサラという言葉なんです
プンニャパーパっていうのはそれほど回数がない
たまに特別にあなたは何やるべきか
何をやってはいけないかとどうしても言わなくちゃいけない時はプンニャパーパっていう言葉が出てくる
だからそんなに論理倫理学的に仏教の世界でそんな倫理学とかそんなことは考えてなかったんだけど
やっぱり概念使うと言葉使うとすごくその意味を考えて
丁寧にちゃんと定義に沿って使ってはいたんです
ほぼイコールだと思ったっても構いません
クサライコールプンニャ
アクサライコールパーパ
でもほぼイコールであって
完全にイコールわけじゃないんです
いわゆる巧みな行為であっても
功徳にならないかもしれません
でも 功徳になる行為はすべて巧みな行為なんです
じゃあそこは全部余計な話で
で まあ今からこの不善心所ってなんですか？ということで
まず不善心所の定義なんですけど
心自体が悪い心かいい心かなん全く言わないんですね
この前も例えたんだから
心っていうのは純粋な水と同じなんですね
純粋な水っていうのはもうどこから取ったって全く同じもので
いろんな種類あるわけじゃないんです
純粋な水としてはいい悪いと何も言えませんし
でも水にはいろんなもの溶けちゃうんですから
この溶けた時点時点で水もいろいろ種類取ったりするんですね
例えばミネラルウォーターにしても
いろんな名前でいっぱい種類があるんだから
どういうことかというと
やっぱり水の中に溶けている物質から区別できているんですね
そこでいい水も悪い水も現れてくるし
飲んでも構いません水もあったし
飲んじゃったらいけない水も出てくるし
例えば毒は飲んだと言ったって
結局この人は水飲んでるんですよ
水飲んでるんだけど死んじゃったと
なぜかというと 飲んだのは水なんで
その水の中に毒が入ってたんですね
そういうことで でも水自体は別に善でもなく悪でもなく
単なる生命としての認識
働きだけなんです ですから
いつでも私は説明しますから
心にはたくさん 心はたくさんない
たった一つ 水でいえばたった一種類しかないと
世の中 世の中ではなくて
他の地球 他の宇宙どこでも水で言えば一種類しかない
でも私たちには海の水とか川の水とかいろいろあるのは
これは水のせいではなくて
水に溶けているもののせいなんです
そこで心の場合も 立派な心とそうでない心と二つ分けられるし
悪いことをする心といいことをすることを心だと二つ分けられるし
強い心と弱い心とも言えるし
できた心もできてない心とも
いろんな言葉で心の状況を説明できるんですね
それはなぜでしょうか？と
あの人はよく心できた人だと
あの人はまだまだ心ができてないですと言えるでしょうし
心は水と同じく同じものであるならば
そんなことは言えるはずがないんですね
そこで ああ 心はみんな同じなんですけど
心に入っているこの心所という心所ですね
心所というものによって差が生まれてくるんだとということが出てくる
またこの心所の説明になりましたけど
今日からこの不善の心
悪い心 罪を起こす心という場合はどんな心所が入りますかと
この十四がありますね
この十四の心所が心に入っちゃったら
その心はもう悪い心 汚れている心
たった十四しかないんです
世の中でこの汚い心と言ったっても
こんな大胆な わかりにくい大変なことではないんです
我々の心はいかに汚れるかっていうこと
この十四勉強すれば それでもOK です
その十四ももっとわかりやすく
ちょっとカテゴリーに入れてるんですね
最初にモーハの四つなんですけども
モーハ アヒリカ アノッタッパ
ウッダッチという四つのセットがあるんです
ウッダッチ で 日本語の言葉はテキストを見てください
モーハは痴ですね 無知のということで
無惨無期上項ですね この四つに基本的な心所と呼ぶんです
いわゆるこの基本的な心所が心に生まれたら
その心はもう紛れもなく悪い
不善な心 だから心は不善であるかということは
この四つで決めちゃいます
次から 出てくる十種類の心所どのようにけど汚れているかということを決めるんです
ここでも汚れているんだと
不善な心だと 次の十種類からどの方向へどのように汚れているかということになると
理解しておきましょう
ですから これはこの アクサラサーダラナ
アクサラサーダラナって言葉なんですけど
どこにあるんですかね
まあ一応アクサラサーダラナという言葉
ちょっと今見つかりませんだけど
どこにあるはずなんです
アクサラサーダラナと言うんです
アクサラ アクサラで まあ一応書いてあげます
アクサラサーダラナ アクサラっていうのは不善
サーダラナというのはコモンという
コモンといえば はい 共通ですね
だから不善の どんな不善な心も共通しているという意味で不善共通心所でいいです
不善共通心所 じゃあ一つ一つ説明していきます
1番目はモウハ モウハの漢字は無知の知ですね
知です この心所のリストの中で
この不善心所だからわかりやすいですよ
誰にでもあることだから
わかりやすいのはいいんだけど
この 4つだけはちょっとわかりにくいんです
他のものはわかりやすいんです
特にモウハ 知といえば無知といえば何が無知かとさっぱりわからない
普通に仏教で無知ですよとか言われると何かもうもうね
悪口言われてる 人間馬鹿にしてるんではないかとも思うかもしれませんし
仏教だったら一般用語だからね
愚か者っていうことは
愚か者っていうのは普通の人々を示して言ってる言葉なんです
別に それなんか人はみんな馬鹿にしてるんではないかと思うかもしれません
それぐらいこの仏教で言ってるこの無知ということは
無知という漢字と知という漢字がちょっと違いますけどね
無知と言おうが 言葉で言う場合はわかりやすいですからね
この無知の状態っていうのはわかりにくいんです
でも仏教でなぜ無知という言葉を言ってますかというと
こういうこと 我々には物事の本当の実際の姿
ありのままの姿はわかっているわけじゃないんです
生まれたまんまで そのまま大きくなって
教えられたまんまで知識を得て死んでしまう
それで他のところで生まれ変わったというのは
そこで教えられたまんまで大きくなって死んでしまっちゃいますから
全ての真理はありのまま
本当の状態を知っていますよと言ったら
それはそうじゃないんです
ですから 真理の本当の姿知りたければ
それなりの努力して頑張らなくちゃいけない
ですから 人間というのは生命の生まれつき抜群の智慧があるよと言ったならば
じゃあ生まれてから成長するということは
どんどん馬鹿になることではないかと聞きたくなっちゃうんですね
それは屁理屈なんです
生まれる時は完全たる洗脳
全知全能だと それからバカになっていくんだとというとおかしいんですね
それを逆に元々何も知らないものだと
でもコツコツと勉強して
経験を積み重ねていろんなものを知るようになったと言えば
なんとなく合理的でわかりやすいんです
ですから 他の宗教と全く正反対
仏教で生まれつきの状態
本来の状態は無知だというんです
それから自分で頑張って
徐々に成長して進化していくんだと
ジャイナ教とか は 人間の魂は完全に全知全能で
不死で至福であると言っていたんですね
全知全能だけではなくて
常に過去現在の未来のことを常に知っているんだと
自分に人の魂は 起きていても寝ていても体がそれ関係ない
起きていても寝ていても一切は知ってるんだ
それは心の状態だと もし本当の心の状態そうであるならば
輪廻転生することによって人間何をやってますかというと
徐々に馬鹿にしていく道なんですね
でもそれはちょっと考えちゃうと何か理解しにくい
我々知ってる場合は 生まれてばっかしの赤ちゃんっていうのは
そんなに物事わかるわけでも何でもないし
生まれる時は馬鹿でどんどん頭が良くなってるっていうことは明確にわかりますでしょうに
ですから 我々の本来の状態
は無知の状態 大乗仏教の言葉でならば
如来の状態は無知そのものである
それは本来の状態だから
存在の元々の状態 それから頑張って
本当に真理はいかなるものか努力して知らなくちゃいけないんです
ですから それは誰しも軽蔑することじゃないんです
決して差別用語じゃないんです
仏教でいう愚か者っていうことは
で これはもう当たり前のことを言ってるだけ
そこで 例えば私たちは人間で生まれちゃうでしょ
人間に生まれたら 目にどんな光見えるかともう決まってるんです
でも世の中にあるのはその七色の三色の色だけですかね
いろいろまた色はあるでしょうに
でも見えない 例えば赤外線ですか
それも色ですけど見えませんし
アルトラバイオレットというのは何です？紫外線
それは全然見えませんし
音も我々に聞こえる音だけですかね
あるのは またいろんな音はあるんだけど
それも聞こえませんし
ですから一応人間になったところで
すべてのものを知るところじゃなくて
これぐらいのことを知りなさいというふうに
もうそこでもうリミットされているんです
それで我々の脳細胞は音はどう？どう音にどう反応して
どう解釈するか 犬猫やら他の動物は音にどう解釈
どう反応するか まあそれぞれまた別々決まってるんだから
だから我々の認識は 自分持っている体によって変わっちゃうんですね
例えばコウモリみたいな動物には
音っていうのは大変な情報を持ってくるんですね
音から三次元で知ってるんですよ
あの あの鳥はなんですか
夜 あのフクロウ？とか
まあもうこっち見ていたっても
後ろにいるネズミをちゃんと知ってるんです
食べられるぐらい大きさのものかどうか
どこにいるかどうか ちゃんと三次元で知ってるんですね
音から知ってるんです
我々にはネズミが鳴いてる声聞いて
あのネズミは三十センチで十センチですよとかわかりますかね
なんとか種類 いくらか種類
なんとかとわかるかもしれませんだけど
あまりわからない そこで音はでっかいだからといって
その虫 その動物はでかいわけないでしょ
ゾウの音とかね ライオンの声とか
すごいデッカいなんですよ
響くんです 体の中に それででっかい動物だからでっかい声出してるんだと
でも あの なんとか虫いるでしょ
あのナッソリ鳴く あの
何て言いますか あの虫
随分でっかい声で鳴いてるでしょ
いるでしょ いろいろ種類ありますけど
リケツとかいろいろ でもたまにこの耳がもう痛いほど鳴くんだけど
探したところでほんのこれぐらいなんでしょう
みんな箱になんかに入れて遊んだりするでしょ？あのスズムシとかね
小さくて でも音を出す場合はもうすごい大きな音を出しちゃうし
ですから 人間には音で
これ目で見たんだから小さいと知ってるんだけど
もし一度も目で見たことがなかったならば
いろいろ神話作っちゃいますよ
目で見えない巨大な幽霊みたいな動物がいて
これがナッソリ鳴ると
あの世から亡くなった人々が出てきて泣いてるんだとかとか
だからお盆祭りやってるんだと言うかもしれません
でもそういう神話できなかったのは
まあ探しちゃったら見つかったんですね
小さな虫を もしあまりも小さくて
ミゾイブシぐらい小さくて見つからなかったならば
やっぱり神話作ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから この私はこの無明の無知のことを説明していますから
我々は知ってるわけじゃないんです
まあ決まられているこの条件の中で
なんか知らされてるだけのことなんですね
知るというよりは その状態は無知だというんです
で 一応研究したりすると
この光というものはいくらか種類があって
それは瞬間瞬間光子通して
分子通して出てきて まあある波通して出てきて
耳に触れちゃう ぶつかったりするんだと
それは一度も体験して来たことないでしょうに
一度も体験したことがないんです
頭で考えてそう言うだけ
私たちに体験できるのは
目を開けたら机見える
全然 まあ机に当たった光が反射して波通して
光子が波通して ある一定の波を作って目に触れてるんだと
全然そんなこと体験できない
だから真理知るっていうことはありえないことなんですね
ある面では そういうことで
人間の状態 普通の状態
無知というんです 特別な怒りみたいな特別な状態じゃないんです
我々の普通の状態 どんな人のどんな生命でも
無知という基本なんです
厳密に仏教的な解釈で言うならば
全ては無常であることを生滅して変化していくという
瞬間瞬間 その時の現れる一時的な現象であること
だからそういうものは存在しないんだと
空であることはわかってないんです
この空というのは 例えばここにマイクロフォンがありますよと言っても
ここにマイクロフォンがあるわけじゃなくて
まあ一時的にマイクロフォンという現象が出てきて
それはそういうふうに認識する
そういう生け花とかね
そういう人間はもうワサワサと作るものからはよく見えるでしょうに
その現象の姿が まあそれほど綺麗でない
それほどかっこよくない
花いくつか葉っぱいくつか持ってきて
まあそれほど変なところにあちこちぐにゃぐにゃになってる
あの植木鉢 何て言いますか
そういう何か入れ物を持ってきて
それに花を植えるでしょ
植えて適当に置いたところで抜群に綺麗なんですね
驚くほど この生け花に使うこの花入れる入れ物というのは全部変なんですね
形が悪くて 色が悪くて
でもじゃあ花を植えてみてくださいと
花を植えたところでも冗談じゃないんですね
ものすごい立派な美しい作品が出てくるんですね
[背景音楽]